[line trilling]
[telephone rings]
Hello.
Hello, may I please speak
with a Mr. Blownoff?
(Anders)
This is he,
and you can call me Dick.
(Adam)
Okay, Mr. Blownoff,
I am telling--
I am talking to you today
from my work,
TelAmeriCorp.
Hey, are you sick
of unblended foods?
'Cause it's--you know what?
Never mind. I suck at my job.
And I suck at my life.
- Good-bye forever.
- Hang on.
Listen, son, I don't bite.
What are you selling?
Stupid freaking blenders.
Well, I'll take five.
How 'bout that?
That's cool.
I mean, honestly,
if I'm being real with you,
I wouldn't buy anything
from me, because one, I'm fat,
two, I'm stupid, three,
I'm fat and stupid combined.
(Anderson)
Listen,
you don't sound fat to me,
maybe a little depressed, huh?
And I've been there.
- Really?
- You know what I did?
I went on a booze cruise
with my friends,
and I was totally cured.
Anyway, blenders...
Well, the blenders,
actually, I take it back,
what I said earlier.
They're pretty cool.
You can make juices.
You can, like,
blend up a boot.
That's how sharp this thing is.
That's how intense it is.
Oh, I actually have a boot here
right now.
Boop.
[imitating blender whirring]
Oh, my gosh, the boot,
it's blending so well.
[imitating blender whirring]
That's funny.
Well, looks like it'll
get to you Tuesday,
and I just want to say
thank you.
You are a great man,
Mr. Dick Blownoff.
(Anders)
And you are a good
goddamned salesman.
Okay, so I'm gonna go ahead
and put you down